various systems
thank you
sorry
so i'm going to to talk about a problem
for which we already have bilinum time
algorithms it's not uh
it's not too hard to devise
solutions in the class p solving systems
of two equations in two unknowns uh what
really matters to me here is to try to
find something that's
as close to optimal as possible
as we'll see because uh that was
motivated by a couple of uh
practical applications i mentioned one
of them in a second
so uh systems of two equations and two
unknowns have shown up uh frequently
recently uh
in large part motivated by problems of
computing the topology topology of a
curve which means uh given a plane curve
here
finding a graph that looks pretty much
like the curve and i'm going to leave it
at that
so trying to discretize this kind of of
curve here by filing points of interest
and then connecting them in a suitable
way and i don't want to define more
precisely what i mean here
concretely what this boils down to in
part
is uh
first of all solving some equations that
will give you the points of interest so
there are these guys in uh in green over
there and in that case if my plane curve
is given by f equals zero f square three
uh these points would be the real
solutions of
f equals zero and the partial derivative
with respect to y is zero
and once you have them you have more
work to do but that's part of the
uh
part of the work
and as you can see there are tons of
references here and it's not exhaustive
that's a very popular subject for
research
i
had to deal with vibrate systems in
another context which was working over
fine fields calling the points in the
jacobian of a curve of genus 2 so as to
describe to define a hyperlink
a
fast hyperleptic uh cryptosystem so that
was work with godaddy and for that we
had a large bargain systems source to
solve with coefficients in a large
prime field
and as well and i'll get back to that in
a minute and as well
that question of two equations two
unknowns it also shows up as one of the
ingredients in an algorithm that was
mentioned a couple of times before are
geometric resolutions uh due to in that
in in that precise version you still
sell insulin and that's kind of a
symbolic homotopy algorithm so your
symbolic amount of p means you are going
to to lift an actual algebraic curve and
then cut it through by the next equation
which leads you to solving systems of
two equations in two nodes but to be
perfectly honest that's that part is not
the bottleneck of the whole process so
it just appears there but there are more
costly steps
so before actually solving systems i'm
going to look at something which is
rather close not quite the same but if
you can do that
you're almost done which is computing
resultants
and these simple resultants the
silverstar resultants of two equations
in
a couple of years
so i'm starting by the simplest case
i am given f and g
when variable y over field k degree d
both so the input has d terms more or
less to the two equations of degree
uh computing the resultant of them the
resultant has one term it's a it's a
number
and it's it's known that you can compute
that in
essentially linear time so this ordered
here means i'm not looking at uh
discarding logarithmic terms up to log
terms
that's a linear time algorithm
so it was known in the in the 60s that
you could compute a resultant from a
suitable twisted uh
polynomial remainder sequence it was
known essentially since
node that you can do it in that amount
of time by dividing conquer process
and so that's the up to the logs that's
the best you can hope for
the input has d coefficients you take
quasi-linear time indeed fine
the
question we are
looking at looks more like this one
actually when instead of having uh
by universe input i have bivariate ones
and uh yeah stop computing the resultant
of this kind of guys is tantamount to
solving the system indeed
so in this case
this is the case that really hurts as we
as we will see
uh
if both guys of degree d
it takes about d square coefficients to
write them in dense representation
the resultant has degree d square in the
variable x
and
you cannot it's not known how to compute
that in an optimal manner the best you
that's known you can use an algorithm to
try shot that will do that or you can
use chinese remaindering theorem to go
back to the universe case if your field
allows it
is d cube and why is that well it's
about d square times the amount of work
you had there so that was optimal
because you were input bound no it's not
optimal anymore and that's really
annoying
uh
going back there oops going back there
in that particular case for instance we
had
equations of degree about i don't know a
couple of thousands deep uh so about
a few million solutions and well that's
fine once you have them we're happy we
that was okay
but we would really have liked to have
something better than this dq algorithm
to compute these million solutions
itself within two weeks if we could have
waited only a couple hours we would have
been glad
fortunately we don't have that
i would have loved to say something
about this case but i i don't have
anything to say
uh so let me move on to what something
which is going to be sub-optimal again
but less sub-optimal
first by introducing a t and then later
on it will become a
integer coefficients but first let me
introduce another variable t
so now we have equations in three
variables
uh imagine we are intersecting two
uh surfaces in three space the resultant
is more or less the equation of the
projection on the here tnx plane
so the input size we have an extra
variable so
from d2 to the cube
the resultant uh we have one extra
variable in degree d square so from the
square to d4 the running time we play
another d square compared to what we had
before still not optimal
less suboptimal because five quarters is
better than three halves but still it's
uh not as good as you would want it to
be
so that that last colon here leads me to
the um to the boolean case
so relying on the the analogy between
polynomials in t and integers i can take
everything i have here and look at the
the case of systems with integer
coefficients instead of looking at it at
a t degree um
i can speak of bit size or
logarithmic height or yeah
bit size would be fine
and everything i said there more
translates more or less directly in the
boolean world
over there all costs were in operations
over k here all costs are in a
boolean
model of your choice
the resultant is a large object it has
this due to the four bits and we can
compute it in that amount d to the five
so here i'll be able to say something so
that's not optimal and the goal is to to
uh to prove to to show algorithms that
get you closer to the optimal not quite
for resultant but for solving systems
which are more than the same thing
so um yeah to define my my actual
question so
i'm not only wanting to eliminate why i
also want to recover it
uh so my idea at first would be
something like that given an f and a g
find a p and an s
such that well we have something that
was described before but in agnes talk
for instance
we
find the solutions of the equations by
means of p of x equals zero and y
expressed as a function of x
so and then there's a little bit of
things that needs to be uh to be taken
care of in order for this to make sense
if the solutions look like that you
won't be able to express them in this
manner because y is a multi to one here
and the usual workaround is to change
coordinates so i will do that instead of
projecting parallel to the y axis i'm
going to project parallel to something
else
and most uh directions of projection
will be fine
there's going to be well that's more
these square points here so they are at
most
but due to the four bad directions
that's one
so that here accounts for the fact that
here what i'm writing are not really f
and g but f and g up to a change of
variable that's just to account for
possible uh
non-generic projections and then there's
also the fact that uh here i'm not going
to want to compute multiplicities of any
kind
so i'm going to the equality i want is a
square free polynomial here which
describes the radical of my of my input
so here everywhere the input is has
coefficients in l a domain like imagine
the integers or k of t and the output
coefficients in the fraction field of it
and that's what i want to do once i have
this well i
i'm saying that from
my point of view the problem is solved
you have probably still have something
to do with it you have i don't know
isolate roots or say something about the
roads but that's not that's not my
problem my problem is computing this guy
and uh everything that we saw for
resultant more or less carries over to
computing these guys up to a small
small precaution i have to take
so again i'm going to uh to look
specifically at these two cases where
there's a notion of length of uh of
coefficients no height as still as i
said uh two days ago
uh so over the integers it's the the bit
size so the logarithmic in any basis you
want and over the polynomials is degree
uh i'm going to assume just like i did
before that the
uh the degree of the input is d and that
the length of the coefficient is the
same d
because that will give me simpler
formulas just uh yeah
you could do it without that assumption
but let's go with d and d it's just uh
just fine
uh they oops
so i want to compute two guys
uh nearly meaning polynomial and
something that gives me y
for the eliminating polynomial it's the
same
thing as the resultant this is a
resultant or a factor or resultant so
it's easy to control its size but these
square bits per coefficient and that's
essentially optimal that this kind of
bound
unfortunately if you don't take any
precaution the other guy is not as well
behaved
and that's something that you see when
you compute lex square no basis over the
integers typically the last polynomial
will be pretty nice and all the other
ones will be pretty not nice
and uh
this is quantifiable by an upper bound
their coefficients here that is a d4
rather than a d square and that's kind
of sharp
so don't compute that compute something
else that
agnes
mentioned in our talk as well
instead of computing as here compute a
twisted version of it
where you multiply it by p prime and
reduce mod p so if you know one you know
the other
and as it turns out this one works
better uh coefficients are smaller and
that's due to well that's due to the way
it shows up naturally uh from the
resultant for instance and the this guy
shows up more than a hundred years ago
in old papers uh this kind of
parametrization was there already and
this one has a better uh bit size bond
in numerical analysis you have uh
the barycentric barycentric lagrange
interpolation which is said to have
better
uh approximation property than the usual
laboratory interpolation it's the same
thing
the bottom line what you once you choose
properly what you want to compute
um
it fits in about d square bits of uh
in your computer
uh
per coefficient sorry so d to the four
in total because you have about d square
coefficient to compute
the goal is to be uh to give an
algorithm close
uh to that as close as we can so sorry i
said bits because i was thinking integer
case if you are in the polynomial case
that's the amount of coefficients in k
the balance here the work in both cases
so the the bottom line is that
in the integer case we can get close to
optimal
and in the polynomial case we cannot so
this question is one of these funny
questions where we have better bit
complexity results than algebraic
complexity results
so in the in the boolean case first
so i'm going to uh
uh whoops
to use monte carlo algorithm i would
love to give deterministic results with
the same cast but i don't know how to do
that
so i'm going to use monte carlo
algorithm we'll see in the next slide
here already i'm going to cha to start
choosing stuff at random
i can get uh i can obtain a running time
uh
optimal up to a d to the epsilon
by using actually techniques that are
that have been around for a while but
not combined in that uh in that way yet
uh so what using symbolic newton
iteration that's no that's an old idea
uh final system solving solving is from
the 80s or 90s
so i'll have to take care of multiple
routes by using if there are multiple
roads by using a deflection algorithm in
that case the one utilis f
and the the slightly new ingredient here
is uh
in order to make this work i also will
use an algorithm due to clear layer and
humans have
four years ago now
that was introduced
that they used for factoring polynomials
for instance and here well it turns out
it also can be uh useful in other
contexts
so um i said at the very beginning that
you can uh it's not too hard to find
polynomial deterministic algorithm for
all these that's true
the best deterministic result is here
that's uh by bouzidine
in the las vegas context and did to the
five monte carlo is easy to find
so yes these are yeah
the more probabilistic you are you are
the better you you can be at least in
theory
and so strangely over the uh in in an
algebraic context the this the id
carries forward but the algorithm do not
uh because that component is missing
only for the case of simple roots there
is something better than the than the uh
the d to the five for instance
and that's that's frustrating but that's
how it is
so the um
this the
the scheme is something which is uh
extremely classical so i'm working with
the coefficients in a domain integers or
a polynomial ring
choose a maximal ideal there so either
reduce not b or specialize at t not
random p or random t naught so i'm
probabilistic
you solve your equations modulo
that
p or t naught
uh that gives you your output uh let's
see what p you can lift it modulo uh p
square p4 p8 as we
uh well we heard about neutron iteration
quite a bit uh in
analytic context that's uh in the
nematic approximation context but it's
the same thing and once you have enough
precision you uh
that's a mistake
once you have enough precision you uh
you go from mod p to the something to
rational coefficients by rational
reconstruction
so the
beginning and the end rational
reconstruction are easy and what is
difficult is the of course what's in the
middle
so um i want to actually write what
newton's iteration looks like because
then we'll be able to see what is going
to be costly so that's a bivariate
iteration so it's i can write everything
first in a uh
in a context of an approximation over
the reals for instance i'll write that
my iterate x n y n
uh is uh improved into x n plus 1 y n
plus 1 by means of this correction term
i have to evaluate f and g and i have to
invert the jacobian matrix
and for the month let me just assume
that i'm close to a root uh to a simple
route where that matrix is going to be
invertible so everything works smoothly
so that's the uh the usual version of
newtonian and there's something
completely similar that exists for
compute for calculating in a in a
nematic context
uh with formulas that are going to be
essential entirely inspired by those
that take your solution say mod p and
that so your polynomials modulo the
prime and that
return your the same solution you want
but modulo you have the square of a
prime and then from power two to power
four and so
it's obviously not the linear algebra
that will be costly here i have to work
with a 2x2 matrix so that's fine
all the work is in the evaluation of the
functions
so in a numerical context it would be
evaluating f g at my root my approximate
root
in this context here what this means is
uh
for f for instance
uh i have to evaluate it modulo this
which means reduce it uh p
and y equals x all that with
coefficients uh modular the power of
your prime
and this is uh that's all that there is
once you can do that all the rest is
going to be easy so you can do that
efficiently everything works fine
so uh
in most instances where these ids were
used in a symbolic context
the idea was that the inputs were given
by means of a straight line program
and then well you have a straight line
for your for your f
this reduction it just makes sense to do
it step by step modulo p and do every
operations like we saw our repeated
squaring in the first talk i think on
monday morning all calculations might be
it's just natural if you have an slp
uh
there's not much to say here just follow
it modulo
in this context of bible equations well
i could assume that they are given by a
by a straight line program but
um often they are not bivariate
equations the ones you have to deal with
usually they are just dense guys and uh
so i'm going to not assume a straight
line program
f is given as a dense part in the middle
of degree
so that's what makes this not
not too easy
so uh here is where the
the difference between the the integer
and the algebraic case
shows up
in the way that this reduction is going
to be done and over the integer case
we're going to use a modification of
of a very strong result by kellyanne
newmars from a couple years ago
i didn't write what was the input there
so uh in a slightly different context
what they uh what they obtained is an
algorithm that computes this kind of uh
composition given a g an s and a big p
all univariate
uh compute g of s mod p
so uh imagine they are all of degree d
uh so the input has d coefficients the
output has d coefficients because it's
reduced
and you have to assume that you're
working in a boolean context
so here in a z mode and z
then in that context you can do this in
essentially optimal time so the beauty
here is in the d to the one plus epsilon
naive algorithms d square this almost
linear time
so up to this epsilon it's optimal and
it's not
known how to extend these ideas through
uh some
to uh an algebraic algorithm
so at the time that was extremely uh
impressive because that uh gave the
first improvement for the complexity of
factoring polynomials or fine fields
in 15 or 20 years
just by me just because this operation
here for instance is
at the core of algorithms for factoring
polynomials all five
so what we are going to do is very close
to this so it's a slight extension of it
to a bivariate situation what we had to
do was more or less computing that
up to the fact that the f was bivariate
this is not a big deal you can take the
calendar massages and make the work in
that context so i'm given my f
what i want to compute is the reduction
of that f modulo this kind of idea which
is computing f of x it's by now x
remains itself and this s that i know so
this and that looks similar
and the results are the same
so now f has
d squared terms this guy has degree d
square we are computing modulo and n
which has about
uh
length d square
so optimal for all this would be about
d4 and indeed it can be done in an
almost optimal amount of time up to that
epsilon the same as up there
so that's uh that's the basic idea for
the algorithm of the integers provided
there's no issue with uh multiple routes
because i assume that i could just run
newton iteration
let me just say what about the uh the
algebraic case yeah in the algebraic
case there are there are solutions uh
for this composition problem this is the
uh very famous algorithm by britain kung
from 78
which gives you at least sub quadratic
again
for that problem here the natural
running term would be d square
and you can bring in dots to d2 a little
bit less than 2 by means of matrix
multiplication this tiny omega here is
multiplication matrix multiplication
exponent so that amount there it turns
out to be less than 2
but not by much very far from the
optimal we saw before but that's an
algebraic algorithm
you can plug that into the scheme we saw
before and uh you you count your beans
and you arrive at the running time which
is d to the omega plus seven half so
less than five but not way less uh
impressive than this one
and
yeah oh yeah
one more slide
and what's making all this work now is
matrix multiplication uh with polynomial
entries so it's a very different ideas
from uh kid layer animals
finally um
how to recover the the general case
so actually this is old technique is
there this is
difficult but uh i don't give any
details so it's fine uh
so uh there's the obvious issue that we
don't know how uh well newton iteration
won't work close to multiple routes so
one easy fix would be to just forget the
multiple roads but if you want to get
them you use a deflation algorithm
and there's a whole lot of them starting
from
in the
work in the eighties biologica watanabe
and mitsui
the one we relied on is due to the ceph
so it because it's easy to control
what's happening in that one you don't
uh well you don't add new variables you
don't have new equations you just work
with your two f and g and you extract
stuff from them uh so at least
it's feasible to control in his context
it was easy no not easy feasible to
control the complexity
uh we couldn't use these results off the
shelf because uh
he
had to say in the multivator keys he had
to do some simplifications that were
that would have been hurtful for the
result in the private case so we had to
rework a little bit everything but at
the in the end we get what we want in
the uh in the bit boolean context
because uh
the calence algorithm is flexible enough
that even
with the deflation stuff it will still
work it does not work for the moment in
the algebraic context
and
any um
yes
so in in this new configuration you also
have an inversion a modular inversion
is the complex the boolean is the same
oh
there's no problem on this one uh
i mean it's harder than evaluation it is
but so for instance what you said the
other day in a parallel context it's not
easy uh
but in a
serial context here no problem it's
another unit an iteration
no issue here
any other questions
so i guess the precursor of my algorithm
with new ones was this paper by humans
where he has this kind of
pseudo-algebraic absolutely
yes can you copy that
uh if i remember where esp had to be
small
yes the p had to be small and here we
we're not really in mod p we have mod p
to a
to a power
i don't want to say anything i have no
idea yeah
all right thank you eric